Speaker 1: The New York Times is a very interesting
report about more than 100 Republicans, including
former Republican officials who are seriously
looking at abandoning the Republican Party
and starting their own third party.
There's a great article by Zachmanoglou published
late yesterday, I believe, in The New York
Times, where he says more than 100 Republicans,
including some former elected officials, are
preparing to release a letter this week threatening
to form a third party if the GOP doesn't make
certain changes.
The statement is going to take aim at former
President Trump's stranglehold on Republicans.
The timing of this could not be more relevant,
given that with the ouster of Liz Cheney,
Republican congresswoman from leadership,
Republicans in the House seem to be committing
to a Trump in twenty twenty two platform.
The preamble to this letter says, quote, When
in our Democratic Republic forces of conspiracy,
division and despotism arise, it is the patriotic
duty of citizens to act collectively in defense
of liberty and justice.
And this is a first step, says Myles Taylor,
who is an organizer of the effort, if you
recognize that name.
That's because Taylor is the former Trump
era Department of Homeland Security official
who anonymously wrote that book condemning
the Trump administration.
He has since acknowledged that what was originally
written, anonymous anonymously was written
by him.
He goes on to say, quote, This is us saying
that a group of more than 100 prominent Republicans
think that the situation has gotten so dire
with the Republican Party that it is now time
to seriously consider whether an alternative
might be the only option now.
We don't yet know the full scope of who else
is signing this letter.
At some point we will when the letter is released.
I am not optimistic that this group of hundred
Republicans can actually make a dent in the
pro Trump Republican Party of right now.
And here's what I mean by that.
We've looked at polling that tells us the
voters right now are basically with Trump.
70 percent of them still believe that Donald
Trump won something like two thirds said they
would leave the Republican Party and follow
Trump if Trump were to start his own party.
Now, I don't think two thirds really would.
Two thirds are saying that they would, some
wouldn't, because they would realize actually,
you know, maybe I don't want to follow Trump.
Part of that two thirds wouldn't just because
of laziness.
It actually takes some effort to leave the
Republican Party.
Some would leave the Republican Party and
follow Trump, but would still mostly vote
for Republicans.
So, you know, we have to understand.
That that two thirds is not if Trump leaves,
Republicans really lose two thirds of their
votes.
But although Trump seems to have meant millions
and tens of millions of Republicans, that
would follow him out.
It's not clear to me that if a hundred Republican
officials leave the party that that many voters
follow them, I think that whatever happens
with the Republican Party in 2022 and 2024
is going to happen from within the Republican
Party unless it's Trump who bails.
Few disagree with me.
I would love to hear from you.
I just don't see any serious willingness from
Republican voters to say, particularly because
they're mostly with Trump.
If some officials leave, I will go with them.
The counterpoint to this is that not that
many have to leave in order to potentially
completely sabotage the chances of Republicans
in 2020.
To many of these 20, 22 races are going to
be very tight, particularly in the Senate,
but in the House as well.
And even if it's true that 70, 75, 80 percent
of Republicans would not even consider leaving
just because Miles Taylor is starting some
third party, and I think that that's the case.
If only a few of them do leave and they are
disproportionately voting Republicans because
remember, particularly in midterms, sometimes
half or more of the country doesn't even vote.
It doesn't take that much to potentially completely
upend the chances of Republicans at taking
back the House or the Senate in twenty twenty
two.
So we have to sort of hold both things.
On the one hand, it is very clear that it's
Trump who holds the cards here.
Trump is still fundraising.
Trump is recreating his communications with
the party, although to a very limited degree
of success.
Those blog posts he's making are only getting
a couple hundred thousand views total.
And it is still a Republican Party in the
House of Representatives in the Senate that
privately many of them despise privately.
Maybe many of them despise Trump or don't
like the direction he's taking the party or
whatever.
But they clearly have calculated if and until
it becomes clear that the voters are no longer
with Trump.
I need to stay with Trump publicly for self-preservation
to avoid getting the the Trump dagger of saying
that person needs to be voted out or whatever.
The case may be so good for these Republican
officials.
I don't think this is going to have much of
an impact whatsoever.
I'd love to hear from you about it.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
And remember that Monday, Memorial Day, that's
not this coming Monday.
It's not the next one.
I believe it's the one after that Monday the
31st.
We are doing a one day membership special.
If you would like to be notified about this
membership special and it is a beauty, just
get on my mailing list at David Pakman Dotcom.
Remember that every day there's really two
shows, there's this show and then there's
the bonus show, you can get instant access
to the bonus show by becoming a member at
join Pakman Dotcom.
It doesn't have to be just the podcast.
Every day we've got that bonus show and you
can use the coupon code better 21 to get a
discount if you so please, at join Pakman
Dotcom.